c'est un instrument de musique créé en
italie au xvième siècle le théorbe gens
de manger à fabriquer celui-ci de ses
propres mains avec 14 corde pour un prix
de vente autour des 2500 euros ceci est
un terme avec lui car sur le manche et
six cordes sur l'extérieur qui sont les
coeurs passe le manche est notamment
beaucoup plus lent l'appliquer sur un
but politique
c'est la forme d'un luth bien sûr on
peut pas dire le contraire mais
il ya une prolongation
au niveau 2 au niveau de la tête de rémy
combien de temps pour le fabriquer là il
ya quatre mois
son activité créée redonner vie aux
instruments de musique à cordes violon
guitare ou contrebasse un métier entre
art et artisanat apparu au tout début du
xvième siècle cette passion jean de
manger la débuté en 1973 avec sa
boutique à versailles
si jamais un générique de l'ébénisterie
je me suis reconverti en matière de
membres ont jeté un truc qui m'a 21-13
faisait des guitares ge
le luthier restaure façonnent les voûtes
et pose les vernis de résine un
savoir-faire exigeant qui nécessite
aussi bien une solide connaissance des
différents matériaux qu une grande
culture technique et historique et
surtout beaucoup de persévérance
quand on enseigne un truc comme ça c'est
les suite après après l'enseignement que
la personne a
le métier en main
deux tours de trouver des possibilités
de s'installer
c'est à dire et cetera
heureusement le métier vous à l'arche de
moins bien la lutte risque d'un métier
il faut être sur le tas pour pouvoir les
avoir à le connaître
on n'apprend pas un métier comme ça en
cinq ans présents pendant dix ans les
20 ans ou 30 ans pour un brin de soleil
depuis qu'il est à la retraite jean de
manger vite à coignières est à 74 ans il
ne compte pas abandonner sa vocation
[Musique]
il faut avoir l'oreille musicale et
c'est pas forcément il nécessité d'être
musicien
le principal système accordé l'un
seulement
aussi longtemps que j'ai ma tête et mes
doigts
le métier mon métier c'est magique
selon un recensement plus de 400 luthier
était en exercice en 2009
un amour du bois et de la musique qui
traverse les siècles
tout comme ces instruments